hey guys how's it going this is Eric its
January 2nd 2019 and I'm back with
another video
yesterday's upload got a lot of
responses a lot of people wishing me
happy new year
a lot of questions and the comments a
lot of like video recommendations
so what I'll try and do is answer at
least a few of the comments from the
previous video and for this one we're
gonna stay in the Budapest Budapest
gambits and just to clarify Budapest is
d4 5 f6 c4 c5 you cannot play the
Budapest
if white doesn't play c4 I move to white
plays like Bishop f4 or Knight f3 then
you have to choose a different opening
is black so there's one question from 0
is the Budapest only effective when
white plays d4 and then c4 the answer to
that is yeah I mean you can't play the
Budapest if white doesn't play d4 in c4
um but now I'm actually just being
reminded there is a really strange trap
which I guess I'll go ahead and show I
wasn't planning to show it before this
video started but it'll be a nice
another nice kind of simple trap I don't
think it's it's a most likely trap but
let's imagine white plays Knight t2 then
I believe II five is still very playable
and the spirit of the Budapest after D
takes d5 Knight g4 let's imagine white
plays just kind of a bad move here and
bad for a few reasons
I'm gonna move pawn to h3 first reason
is it just okay obviously allows black
to take the pawn on e5 but also it
allows black a different and stronger
option and it's actually black to move
and just get a winning position after
the next move if you don't see it
feel free to pause the video and just
find the absolutely crushing move for
black in this position the move is very
aesthetic move not III trapping the
Queen if the pawn takes on III then
there would be Queen h4 with mate after
g3 Queen takes g3 and the game ends in
six moves so that's cool but I don't
think too many players play 92 I guess
we could look it up and you can explore
it for anyone has fallen into this trap
yeah let's see how many players have
actually played into this we switch
views here and let's go forward opening
book Wow 92 92 doesn't even make like
the top what is this like the top 10 to
15 moves I assume it has been played
okay there's still been a few thousand
games here 594 oh wow
seven people played h3 and then everyone
found 93 nice F takes you three how did
white win this one game wait what what
is this view game how do you not what Oh
black just flagged here that's so
unfortunate and he lost 24 rating points
probably disconnected in something
that's got to be rough getting to a
position like force maid flagging there
is some background noise hopefully it's
not too bad I guess I'll find out after
I finish the recording but okay let's go
back and let's stay focused and continue
some more some more questions there was
one question from the sky hello Erik at
war
minutes what's up okay I got my fresh
towel this is very important where am I
Here I am okay that back here of people
can see this towel just delivered I'll
probably edit this out or maybe I won't
who knows at 4:08 what happens if white
plays Knight c3 instead okay so the
position that the person's referring to
what is his name
Rui Gomes or Gomes so this is actually
another main variation of the Budapest
arguably one of the most liked main
lines after Knight g4 let's sleep it
should f4 knight c6 9.3 Bishop to b4 a
check it's this position where it let's
say white doesn't go for this line where
he's potentially falling for for this
early checkmate trap but rather plays
Knight c3 for this I want to show
actually a full game which happened back
I want to say in in 1918 between Akiba
Rubinstein playing black and Milan
vidmar playing or sorry
Akiba ruins teen playing white Milan
Vidmar playing black a very beautiful
game and it goes to show what happens
when white gets a little bit overly
greedy and is a bit too materialistic
and in the following variation white
will manage to hang on to material and
and defend the pawn but black will get
some compensation so the move to play
here is Queen e7 attack the pawn now the
difference between the knight coming to
c3 and d2 is the fact that in this
position the Queen is not obstructed and
the Queen can to land on d5 and that's
what happened in the game simply
defending the pawn and if we notice
there are three defenders and three
attackers one two three so the plant
can't be taken right away so black goes
for
exploitation of some other targets
starting with Bishop takes c3 doubling
Mike's pawns and then going for Queen a3
and now we can see okay the the Queen
side pawns are a bit weak especially the
c3 pawn not having any defenders and
okay in the game white played rook to c1
I do want to note that a normal-looking
move like Queen to d2 can be met with a
very nice move Queen a5 keeping an eye
on the c3 pawn and also targeting the e5
pawn and if I'm not mistaken black is
just guaranteed to Anna pawn back in
this position as there's no way to keep
both of these pawns defended so yeah in
this game white played rook to c1 if we
notice a bishop defends a rook from a
distance so that can't be taken and at
first glance it might seem like black
could just take on a two but I will say
this is perhaps a bit overly greedy and
taking on a two is just bad it allows
white to play this move pawn h3 and then
this Knight sadly has to go back to h6
and probably just gets a bad position
for black so rather than taking on a two
black can play a nice sort of gamma ting
move pawn f6 giving up on trying to win
the e5 pawn straight up and simply going
for the trade to to keep some initiative
now in the game white took on f6 and
black recaptures with the Knights so
black is officially just down a pawn in
this position but okay has some attack
against the Queen and there's there's a
few factors which actually give back
some nice compensation here the first
thing is that black is ready to castle
very soon and white is a bit slow to
Castle White's King is going to be stuck
in the center for at least the next next
few moves
and then also the Queen on a3 is
actually quite quite annoying eyeing
many different targets that light has to
keep a constant eye on so in the game
white played Queen to d2 black plays d6
ensuring that that Bishop is obstructed
can't get away with any Bishop takes e7
shenanigans white played Knight to d4
black castles pawn III and now we get to
a key moment where I think starting with
Black's next move every single move for
the rest of the game was either a
capture or a threat as black now has
really nice forcing combination starting
with the simple Knight takes on d4 and
now if we notice here it looks like
three different things can capture back
on d4 but we should point out the Queen
can't capture back because it's tied
down to the rook and the e pawn doesn't
necessarily want to capture back either
because it would open up the e-file and
leave the bishop a bit less defended so
what was provoked to take off at the C
pawn the problem with taking back at the
C pawn is it opens up this diagonal and
it allows black to keep the initiative
in a very nice fashion with the next
move 90 for simply hitting the Queen but
more importantly forcing the Queen off
of this diagonal and wherever the Queen
goes assuming it's a safe square black
can deliver a check and take away
White's castling rights and that's
exactly what happened the Queen also has
to stay guarding their rook so white
played Queen to c2 and then after Queen
85 check why has nothing else but to
move the King King e2 was played and now
the next move was very impressive from
black and it's a type of move I don't
know if I would consider playing myself
maybe I'm considerate but it's a
difficult move to play because black is
already down upon and the next move
sacrifices more material so if you want
to pause your video and at least try and
consider some different option
it's black to move keep the initiative
and it may seem like a move
perhaps Bishop f5 is is good enough but
Vidmar in this game do not hold back and
just sacrifice the rook for the bishop
rook takes off for trading off one of
whites only developed pieces and also
forcing the e-file to open up and we see
in this game that initiative and peace
activity was way more importance than
material which is the case for a lot of
gambit openings so white took back and
now Bishop f5 and nice thing here black
continues making threats the main threat
of Bishop f5 is just my g3 attacking the
king the Queen and the rook and then
also of course black wants to bring in
the rook to e8 and exploit the king
along the e-file and this is already
very very difficult for a white to
defend what happened the game white
played Queen B to rook e8
and now King f3 a sad move but I mean
what else to do
the king is trying to find shelter black
play Knight to d2 check team to g3 light
comes back to e4 and now something
slightly unusual happened because you
would think white is just trying to hold
on for dear life and it would make sense
for white to at least repeat the
position and move back to a3 and see
what black is up to but white seemingly
self-destructed and played the move king
h4 which is not the safest place for the
king if we see in this position White's
King is the most active piece not what
you want at least in the early middle
game and from this position it was just
a matter of bringing more pieces in and
finishing off attack nice to move rookie
six threatening made in one Bishop e2 is
played rook h6 check
Bishop h5 and now now we can start
calculating until forest mates I'm
pretty sure there's force mate in three
moves in this position if you want to
pause the video black to move mate and
three
shouldn't be too difficult the move is
rook takes h5 now after King takes h5
the fact that the queen is aligned with
the king opens up a lot of discovered
check possibilities and after Bishop g6
check white just resigned as oh did I
lie I think I lied or did I lie no I
didn't lie I was imagining f5 black
queen but f5 is illegal because the
bishop is checked so it was made in
three from that position
the only legal move for whites is king
g4 and then Queen h5 is mates so this is
a really nice just kind of demonstrative
game showing what to do in this Knight
c3 variation if white does try and
perhaps be a bit more greedy and hold on
with a pawn I think the key move from
earlier we go back to this moment after
rook c1 the key move is pawn a6 to
accept that they'll be down upon and
just focus on initiative now I do want
to actually go back to the other moment
to just show what would happen if white
tries to repeat the position after 92 kg
394 King f3 was of course a better try
and this is actually a really good
attacking exercise to try and put
yourself in the situation this black
like pretend it's a serious game and ask
yourself what would you do here how
would you continue the attack I mean the
position looks really good you have a
bishop and I ate the Queen in it rook
all having potential to work together to
meet the king but what's the best
continuation and I think what I'll do is
just show the absolute best continuation
very nice variation in which which just
continues making threats and so white is
as essentially paralyzed so the move to
play here is actually to bring in
another attacker in this case a pawn and
to play the nice move pawn h5 let's
imagine white play is a move like Bishop
to d3 then black simply has Bishop to g4
and then once the king is forced on the
e-file very bad things will happen for
example Knight g3 and the black is
winning a lot of material if not meaning
so for that reason after each five White
will be inclined to play h3 and now
another very nice move from black pawn
h4 and idea of this move is simply to
over control the g3 square so that now
black is threatening Knight t2 which is
simply devastating if white allows it 92
would force white to give away the Queen
and black would go on to win the game so
why doesn't have too many ways to escape
let's imagine pawn to g4 creating some a
safe Square vog to then black can
continue with 92 check and after King g2
the checks continue Bishop e4 check the
King has to move to one of these squares
and now we see that the knight is bound
to come to f3 say King G 19.3 King g2
and we actually have a windmill
situation a windmill in chess is when
you have continual discovered checks to
to win material in this case black can
capture the d4 pawn white is forced to
just continue moving the King King g1
neither three check King g2 and this is
a position where white is just
completely paralyzed and if you turn on
the engine there's no immediate way to
just to win it but that
will suggest some move like Queen c5 and
say the evaluation is about minus five
because white has just so few moves and
I was doing some digging earlier and
apparently one of the plans for black is
to play Bishop c6 and then rook e1 and
then eventually win material by taking
the rook on h1 just to demonstrate this
let's imagine a three Bishop c6
rook d1 rook e1 takes takes King g1 and
now another kind of windmill maneuver
Knight f3
kingi - in the night d2 hitting the
bishop and after a king g1 they take
South Lawn King takes f1 Bishop takes h1
I think we can stop there black is up a
piece and on the way to win the game so
that was very deep analysis from from
this position which is already like
seemingly very good for black but I
think that was a nice demonstration how
to just continue to make threats and
keep the initiative until you finish
things off so I think I'll end it there
I mean there's so much more I can talk
about regarding the Budapest I know
there's a lot of questions yet to be
answered but but keep them coming
I'm hoping to do more videos in the
coming days and the killeen weeks if you
have questions if you have video
suggestions leave a comment below and
I'll see you guys in the next video